When I talk to graduate students in education policy today,
two things stand out: One, the caliber of their methodological training, and
two, how little time they say they spend reading or thinking broadly about
education. When we discuss what they're learning, the answers tend toward the narrow,
ahistorical, and, well, thin. For example,
those training to research teacher quality have devoted remarkably little attention
as to why career ladder models have failed in the past,
or even to what it really means to be an effective teacher.
A lack of history and context can lead researchers to overinterpret
findings or miss obvious caveats. Just for instance:
We should always keep in mind that higher test scores may reflect better instruction, or
just increased test preparation, and that the answer really matters!
Let's be clear: While methodological chops are great,
we need scholars who also possess historical memory wisdom and judgement.
I hope those preparing tomorrow's researchers can rise to the challenge.
What do you think education researchers need to know? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe, for more research and videos from AEI.